and we're live good to be here
talking in front of people
we are all hanging out and having a good
time so
i had a great time
at the mgm grand garden arena
we're all here are you actually mexican
or is that alive
um
so
no sound still
hello
hello
hello hello
okay there you go he says
so yeah um kill tony's about to happen
in about two hours
i'm here in my abode
abiding
in my abode
waiting for the time
when the show will start
having a good time just chilling out
having a good time and all that
um
so yeah i did the little show at the mgm
grand garden arena 16 800 people
opening up for joe rogan and tony
hinchcliffe brian simpson
um so yeah it was a good time and then
we watched the ufc and then we had a day
on sunday just to chill out and explore
and i went to the
mandalay bay beach
uh it's like an artificial beach with a
wave pool and some very
um
young lifeguards
imagine if you're an old person getting
saved by a young person
they were there saving lives
um are you enjoying independence day yes
i'm independently enjoying it
you know a lot of people enjoy
independence day with other people
that's really not what this holiday is
about it's about more independence not
dependence so yeah i haven't been
spending any time with my dependents on
independence day because that would
defeat the purpose i have instead been
enjoying my freedoms as a free young man
ignoring my progeny
and
just being independent you know
nobody has been
near me or touched me
today
i in fact cut my own hair
and i'm beginning to regret how short i
cut the bangs
the bang area
this one the side is way shorter on that
side
but hey you know it's not really about
the looks it's about having a good time
and we're all having a good time so
that's all that really matters
and just on how to be a better whale
watcher is that not on the recipe
are you attracted to britney les esma
yes
i'm in my dependent
if you know what i mean
oh jesus christ
this guy's [ __ ] his child
anyways the internet is not always what
it's cracked up to be we should be
internet independent
um
yes
okay so
you know what is in the news there's a
mass shooting today
in uh chicago area
um
brittany greiner pen's handwritten
letter to biden
and uh are the russians have captured
one of our star at wnba players
you know these russians they really
don't know anything about
american
pop culture
if they think
or we're going to do something about
that
the wnba no
we need to see the ending of this season
of
that sport
um but yeah it's
unfortunate whenever anyone is jailed
for a harmless crime such as marijuana
or
antidepressants or whatever she's in
there for
um
she has a wife as all
of the best female athletes do
they should have their own league
um
russia off season
here she had cannabis oil in her luggage
oh so they're accusing her of smuggling
which just means sneaking in
because she wasn't trying to sell it
she's
wnba player after all they're swimming
in cash
um so yeah i mean if she's just doing it
for her own personal use like what does
it really matter
but you know we're in no position to
judge russia for their backwards-ass
laws because we were just there about 20
years ago
arresting people for the [ __ ] like
this
they're only 20 years behind
until it's 50 years
behind us then we can start criticizing
um
yeah we should get brittany
back
it would be important to make sure that
people are not
trapped
hopefully if i get kidnapped people come
rescue me
um
i can is about to get banned in chicago
is just called everyday i'm on marijuana
have you tried detail or any other thc's
well the thing about chicago is that
this happened in highland park which i
think is a suburb
uh with a lot of whites so this is
hitting people
[Music]
on what was supposed to be a day of
family celebration
so the thing about um
mass
shootings my god this guy's looks so
[ __ ] up he looks like a skeleton looks
like a little pomeranian of a human
he looks like a poodle he doesn't have a
very substantial head
his uh brain is felt small i bet
um and he's already thrown his life away
with all these tattoos he's just like
not gonna care about [ __ ] apparently
um but yeah mass shootings happen in
societies that are not
uh in a healthy place and where people
feel hopeless and don't feel connected
to the people that are around
and i don't wonder why they don't feel
connected to a society that says be on
your own make it on your own we're not
going to help you we're not in anything
together
we're not going to do any group projects
together
and we're not going to help build cities
that help foster people
we are going to make
cities that are the bare minimum
of
money that we have to
spend we're gonna spend as little money
on people as possible and hopefully you
do well
and uh people feel that in one way or
another it might not be directly
a conscious thing but if you treat
people shitty and don't give them as
much money as they need but instead give
them the minimum amount possible then
they're going to be stressed out they're
going to be working all the time they're
going to be
abusing each other
and
this is what you get
if you want to stop mass shootings give
money to everybody
give money to workers give money to
uh people who are not just billionaires
um but yeah i mean
mass shootings
i mean if you just don't take care of
your people and give everyone guns
then
it's gonna be a chaotic situation people
don't feel connected to each other we
don't feel like we're on the same team
and if we're not on the same team
then it's
that it's um then it's easier to do
horrible things to each other but we are
all in this together we are all the
human rights if nothing else
and we are uh united in our common
struggle for
our species uh continuation and we
should be united in that
and not just um
you know primitive tribalism
um but yeah i mean i'm in chicago it
takes
several hours to get over here so
i'm chilling
you know there's
shootings everywhere so
what do you think of andrew yang's basic
income idea i think it's a good stop gap
but
ideally i'd want to see workers get paid
a fair share of what they bring into the
company and not the minimum amount
possible and i think if you pay workers
fairly and inject more money into our
middle and lower class than all the
problems that we see
that we see will sell themselves
you can't say that around these parts of
texas free bread bread and chop
what the hell happened to bread and chop
i hope bread and child is okay
i hope he doesn't get confused for
brendan's job yeah when was the last
time he tripped it's been a while
excited for tonight's episode of kill
tony i heard it's a good one i didn't
get to see all of it
but um
i had another show that night so i had
to jet but yeah the montgomery's i heard
were great
and uh i heard it was a great show
yeah i did a joke that bombed on kilt
i'm glad that it came out already i'm
glad it's not today's episode i [ __ ]
it up i was supposed to say i like how
he calls zoomer's gen z but i said i
like how we call gen z zoomers
um because the joke is about the word
gen z or the phrase gen z and not
zoomers but it made it sound like i was
talking about zoomers
yeah i don't know sometimes the crowd
that kill tony isn't really ready to
hear
political stuff they're like they're
suspicious of that
and
they're not ready they're not broken in
they just have a minute and they're like
thinking about [ __ ] instead of just
enjoying it so it's sometimes a
different
type of way that they take [ __ ] in than
other times
a moment of silence before monday
night's game against the minnesota twins
and have cancelled the post game
fireworks
um yeah i mean we just don't treat
people very well and people are shooting
each other we need to start treating
people better and then people will like
each other and there'll be less
shootings
i mean if we just
you know there's a lot of homeless
people because homes cost a lot
and
we don't pay people enough money
so we need to fix our country and
you know just this
idea of like hating communism prevents
us from doing so much common sense
things
that
is annoying
views on celibacy celibacy is not a good
way to go
ideally we'd be [ __ ] a lot and
getting to know each other but in this
corrupt uh society
you know it might be better to not dip
your dick into it or
you know
accept cox into your [ __ ] and you know
douse your vagina in whatever our
society has to offer
because i think there's a lot of [ __ ]
up [ __ ] going on
in our world
and it's
better to not dip into it if you don't
have to
but if you can find someone
who you can
dip dicks and
you know soak vaginas in
then it's ideal
we should we should be [ __ ] more and
i think like not [ __ ] is an important
part of keeping us
um
docile
and keeping us working for the man and
uncomfortable and unhappy and
making this uh
more something that the elite like
so i think [ __ ] is a good way to
fight against the powers that be when
you should be [ __ ] each other
because for some reason the powers that
be hated every
every uh
you know major society has a law against
[ __ ] too much
and i think that uh that might have been
necessary back in the day when you have
a society that's ruled over by a single
entity but now we have the internet and
communication and we can uh rule over
ourselves that we don't need a single
leader to worship
uh so we can start [ __ ] more and
getting connected on a more grassroots
basis i think once people start [ __ ]
we start like
uh forming
individual small atomized communities
and uh it's harder to get a larger
community just don't [ __ ] anybody and
then we're all not [ __ ] together so
we can all be a part of this larger
grand country but if we start [ __ ]
each other
then we can
create small little communities and then
branch out and create
lots of uh small communities that are
united together
through the internet and through
technology
but you know if you're back in the
agrarian days
one way to keep everyone on board is to
limit the amount of [ __ ] choose a
[ __ ] partner and together
come to us for all your other needs if
people aren't happy then they're more
likely to go to a central government
and a king
to get their [ __ ] figured out but if
we're all [ __ ] each other then it's
like i don't need biden
i just need to
i don't i don't need biden i just need
to start [ __ ] my neighbor
oh i need a plumber why don't i just
start [ __ ] a plumber
i don't need biden to hire a plumber for
me
uh i think a lot of good things happen
when we start [ __ ] and [ __ ] has
been controlled for so long
um
um
[Music]
housing prices need a lower maybe we
need to protest more like china with the
main
land trying to take hong kong back yeah
i mean we need to
change the united states government to
be more democratic and less controlled
by
uh rich white people
who are men
and the elites who have
created this country to be undemocratic
so that they can control it
um
which continued guess where he most
nervous to perform in front of pride joe
rogan
let's go brandon
i like how the left uses brandon now to
be like yeah we don't like him either
this was our olive branch to you [ __ ]
morons
and you don't even like that you don't
like us pandering to you
you just need to be spanked and beaten
and have bernie sanders come in your
throat
that's the only thing you'll respect
because that's the only thing that'll
fix this country you know that you're
wrong that
if you have your way that you're gonna
live in a [ __ ] handmaiden's tale
1950s
country that doesn't work we've already
done your way for the last
70 years since after
this the world war ii after you shot jfk
we've tried your way these capitalists
never want to admit their faults
it's like there's nothing wrong with
capitalism anything that's wrong with
capitalism is actually socialism and we
just need to do capitalism more and
things will get fixed
but
we've done capitalism and it's polluting
our planet it is creating a large
underclass of poor people
and it is giving all our resources to
the rich and leaving us
destitute
and uh it's not sustainable
you starve the
majority of the population of money and
they're gonna be
uh anxious and stressed out and
shooting each other but if you infuse
the population
okay we're back
and at it
hopefully everyone is figuring it out
named a local rapper oh no
uh several of them
contain reference to mass shootings
we create sick people why would we not
create sick people we have a society
that doesn't care about people and
doesn't treat them well or give them
anything
um
yeah i mean
we just need to take care of people
um
do you ever miss being an engineer i
really wasn't an engineer i've did it
for a little bit i dabbled in
engineering and
i was not really up for it the people
who were in engineering didn't really
want me and i didn't really want to be
there
um i'm much happier doing com no i never
wanted to do engineering even when i was
sleeping in my van i was like i don't
wanna i'd rather be doing this than
sitting in a cubicle i'm lying to myself
and stuffing my [ __ ] inside my body so
that i don't
get fired and
ugh
yeah that's i don't wanna live like a
[ __ ]
a cow
okay i'm not a cattle i'm not a piece of
uh furniture i'm a human being and i
need to express myself
i don't want to stuff down the most
creative and
best parts of myself so that i can
function for a corporation that's
not human i no i don't want to do that
i'm not
i don't think anyone should do that i
think it's a horrible way to live and i
think we should all be uh free from that
uh so yeah i mean
it seems like the usa is the only
country not improving
well you know
at least we're holding everyone else
back as well
i think that um
america was the first country to
legalize weed to a significant degree
in most of our states we were the first
country to legalize gay marriage these
[ __ ] europeans act like they're so
much better than us they didn't legalize
marriage or weed first
we did
because we lead the charge we hold
everyone back and if we do it then other
countries will do it
we are at the forefront the people that
are the
most progressive here are more
progressive than anywhere else
and we have the ability to change things
here in the rest of the world
and we don't because we'd rather uh
engage in the group project of
preserving the wealth of the rich that
is what
the main point of america is is to
preserve
the wealth where it is
um and in fact that should not be our
project we should in fact get better and
improve and give money to a lot of
people
god damn i cut my bangs so short
um but uh yeah
that lag though it's our lag what's in
korean and we're going on july 4th like
a patriot
yeah i mean um
i'm uh
i was born in america as far as i'm
concerned i've been american for as long
as i can
think so you know i'm more as
i'm as american as i can be um obviously
if you look at
ancestrally i'm not that american but
you know i thought we were all about the
individual i thought we don't think
about our past only about the present
and who we are
as individuals so individually i'm as
american as you can get you couldn't get
more american you might go watch a white
guy who moved here when i was two
and think you're being more american but
i'm more american than that guy
um
so yeah something funny we could watch
is like
tacos
let's watch some tacos
um
we could watch
what it means to be an american or
something
um
do you have any mustard no
idea i think capitalism is just one step
removed from feudalism we have kings and
now we have billionaires it's like
maybe we should progress past
billionaires instead of just sticking to
this one system when everything is
telling us to change
we're just stubbornly sticking to this
way of doing things
even though it's uh
torturing us and killing us to do it
this way
we're so stubbornly clinging on to this
and instead we should evolve and
progress as a society
uh instead of just doing
what we're doing
american accessories is convenience
where we tell ourselves and then and
when we lying behind some ways it's
always
tucked away with an excuse do you like
mustard oh this looks like logic with a
playboy center cap in the painting
thank you that's by um
let's buy
uh chris rogers
amazing painting i got all these
paintings of myself that people have
sent me and then
i um
i hang it up in my [ __ ] in my room and
then it looks like
it's like a shrine for me which doesn't
seem very very uh
very healthy but what are you gonna do
um
yeah i mean there's a lot going on
we're just enjoying our time and we're
having a good time so
what else can you say
what else can you say about this night
um
we could
well the thing is like i don't want to
be too negative on america
but i mean it's kind of sad like what
we're doing i just think that we should
uh
not look at the past but look at the
future and what we can do with this
country of ours and where we can take
this [ __ ]
let's take it off jumps and ramps and
just [ __ ] do crazy [ __ ] with it
instead of just like doing what we did
in the past
let's instead do awesome [ __ ] and do
things that no one else has done before
instead of just trying to do what we did
in the past really well
let's just go to the past and live like
it's the past
i don't think that's
that's just fun
and people are like trump was such a
good president
but then like the supreme court says
like you can't abort babies anymore and
contraception they're going after and
it's like
this isn't
this isn't the world that anyone wants
to live in
um
trump
i mean
i think that
overall trump is like a bad president
um
uh
i think that uh
like
it's it's fun to be like
oh let's just stick to what we were
doing nothing we did in the past was
wrong everything is fine don't worry
about it
and it's not as fun to be like
we gotta change [ __ ] we gotta get better
let's fix [ __ ] uh things are wrong
things are going badly
and it's more fun to be like [ __ ] that
[ __ ] these people trying to improve
things i'd rather do whatever the [ __ ] i
want to do and be happy and do anything
that i want
but uh
i don't think that's
the way to go i think that um
i think
if you ignore your problems it gets
worse instead of getting better instead
of just being like oh this sucks i'm i'm
so struggling and stuff i think it's
better to be like let's [ __ ] fix it
and
figure [ __ ] out together
um and it's a more adult thing to do and
there's
like if you just ignore that [ __ ] and
just try to have like a fun mindless
time then you're not happy deep down you
know
that [ __ ] is [ __ ] up and you're you
have to turn off your logical mind
and instead use your like primitive mind
to figure [ __ ] out
and uh
you're not happy if you have to turn off
your brain
if you have to turn off your brain you
become a very
stunted sad gross person
i think instead we should be not stunted
or sad but awesome and logical and turn
our brains on so they're just feeling
things we should also think about things
like if you have to turn off your brain
to be happy then you're not going to be
happy humans are not just feeling
machines no matter what these [ __ ]
crystal wielding
mumus will tell you
you just have to feel it within yourself
now you also think you also have to like
engage in logic in
the rest of the world i'm not talking
about some ben shapiro logic
i'm talking about [ __ ]
science and
you know figuring out what the [ __ ] the
world is actually about instead of just
like trying to find it the oldest book
you can find and worshiping it you
should um
you know like figure out
what the best way to run a country is
and it's not by being mean to poor
people
it's about [ __ ]
making sure everyone has food and
shelter
and then letting them pursue their
passions and be awesome people
um
am i using the video cap [ __ ]
i don't want to be using the video
capture device
properties
audio input capture
i'm going to delete all this
and this one i'm gonna try to figure out
hello
hello
okay is the audio better now
cern is awesome it's the future whatever
whatever
um
let me know how the audio is
in the comments just let us hear the
material you're going to use fool
why would i do that
i get paid so much to reveal my material
when i reveal it
this is not for material
a lot louder well i'm glad i got
captured my
shitty thoughts and shitty audio
um
yeah i'm sorry that i was using shitty
audio no one told me
this is the standard this is the audio
that you should come to expect
especially if i have this sure mic in
front of my face
um
yeah i uh i was using the camera audio
the whole time
[ __ ]
um welcome to california please turn off
your brain lamell yeah that's where you
turn your brain off not west virginia or
alabama or mississippi you have to be a
real mo mode i think that's the way to
run your countries
the way those
fugatis do
so here i'm playing catan i need wheat
and i need rock
um i'm not seeing
wheat and rock in the same area that i
can go on
[ __ ] i was gonna go there
so i'm going to have to improvise
and methinks i am going to go
well rock and wheat are right here
um
wheat is right here
i can get the wheat pork but that's not
a lot of wheat i could get
this brick port
and then convert it into rock
in an arduous fashion or i could try to
go all the way up here try to get this
rock eventually
what i'm gonna do
is i'm gonna go here and build two roads
uh [ __ ]
[ __ ] man
this is gonna be
tough for rooney
i could go here
uh
i have 10 seconds or i could go here
um they're both the same
i'm gonna go here
that way i just need
two
of whatever
to get do whatever
oh [ __ ]
this game is [ __ ]
okay
so
i might go here
because i have the brick port
um i have
i have wood
i might go here that takes one two three
roads which is a lot or two roads here
i don't know what i'm gonna do
i could try to go here
i should have tried to go here
um
yeah i think i'm going to aim for this
right here
and then eventually aim for this
um
let's go here
so yeah this is my life i play a lot of
katan and do a lot of stuff uh
oh [ __ ] justin watkins is in line right
now i should get over there soon
um
yeah that's the good thing about being
regulario is that i can just stroll in
whenever i want and just fart
all over the people waiting in line
but i should get over there
soonish i don't know why i started this
game i'm sort of
um
not uh thinking in a
normal way i'm just thinking because i'm
streaming i'm like what's fun to stream
me just sitting here or me actually
doing something
uh
but yeah i really want that
oh
man
what the [ __ ] man
i'm gonna go right here
steal from
no one really has anything black and
blue
black has more development cards
i'm right here and then wait for another
wood brick
to show up in my life
god damn it
but yeah i am doing katan right now
uh asians did build railroads uh we were
here in the 1800s
you know which makes asians more
american than a lot of irish people
but it's not a contest i don't want to
besmirch the
irish a lot of the asians that did come
here were then kicked out in the chinese
exclusion act
so we weren't able to be like the irish
and suffer as they suffered
but you know we were here okay you got
to recognize
that we were here and stuff
so
you know
asians as a
diorama as a pentathema
as a parent panorama
as a pantheon
as like a group
we have a lot of history here it's not a
continuous history because of the
chinese exclusion act but we were here
[ __ ] okay you gotta respect it um
yeah does katan get your creative juices
flowing yeah sometimes it's just like a
way for my brain to be occupied
so that i'm like you know
so my mind isn't just mindlessly
floating around without any structure if
i'm in playing catan there's like
i'm uh i'm thinking about something at
least you know like there's a purpose
and
you know my mind is uh focused on
something
instead of just like the
randomness that is
life
and there is a structure
and i think it's good to have structure
and then you can find creativity within
bounds and playing outside the bounds
and inside but if there's just
free-for-all i think it's too chaotic
and
it's not formed enough
but whatever
um but yeah there's a kill tony tonight
i have some jokes lined up should be a
good time let's all have a good time
i'm excited and
looking forward to it
and all that jazz
um yeah so
sound off in the comments stop being the
best americans
um
[Music]
yeah what is really the deal with the
whole
thing that we got going on
we're just living life having a good
time
winning at certain parts losing at
others but using the losses to get
better so that we can win later and um
you know everything's a learning lesson
even the wins even the losses
um
i can't wait to
wait to meet hans and shake his hands
view okay
so asians are pretty cool i think asians
are very
you know
uh they're just like
just sort of
uh quiet and nice and pleasant
i think asians uh we need to be more
uh proud and more
you know gung-ho and like
chasing after things and
thinking more creatively instead of just
being like oh i just gotta
you know pay my taxes and
play the game correctly i think instead
we should be badass and
you know
embrace the creative individuals
that we have and are
um but yeah i mean i love asians i just
think that uh
asians are very different
and very unique in some ways and
not in others
and
[Music]
yeah i just think that asians
are great people you know i think
there's a lot about us that is the
future of humanity
and some stuff that is not the future
i think like being civil to each other
is very important
[Music]
and
i think that uh
um
like we got it figured out with hygiene
and stuff
but i don't know if we have it figured
out in terms of like honoring
individuals and respecting individuals
and stuff
[ __ ]
give him what he'll give me wheat i
don't need that
there's a strong asian woman to hold him
down
and stay disciplined um i would rather
not like that you know i don't think
that um
being held down is really that great
i think that um
you know like just being yourself is a
good person
as a good thing for a person i don't
think like people need to be reprimanded
and abused to be good people
but such is uh
you know
the idea behind uh
a lot of uh ancient ways of treating
people like oh you got to be tough the
tougher the better and i don't think
that's necessarily the case
um i think that um there's many
different ways to be a person
and we should embrace
all those different varieties
instead of um
just
being like the tougher the better or
whatever
i don't think that's a good way of doing
things
okay so i'm uh doing all right it's a
pretty good game
yeah i mean some people think like
holding people down is the best way to
treat people and i don't know if that's
necessarily the case
um comment on bobby lee i think bobby
lee's wonderfully talented beautiful
person i mean he's just made for comedy
he's uh
he looks funny and if he wasn't doing
comedy i don't know if um
it would make a lot of sense
uh any in any other capacity and i think
that's not a bad thing i think that's a
good thing i think we need people that
are like him instead of like office
workers that are going to press a button
and kill
millions of afghanis we need goofy guys
but why
why why do you do this
you know i feel like that's way better
than like
i'm very serious
and uh tell me what to do and i'll do it
even without thinking because i hate
thinking
and i think we need more of that in the
world and i think there might be a like
a
unconscious bias to create more serious
humorless [ __ ]
and i think that's a very bad bad thing
i think uh bobby lee is a beautiful
person and we should honor and respect
brother bobby to the utmost
because he is
um a necessary component of what we need
in the future
and a way of thinking that is different
we don't need more people who think the
same we need all different types of ways
of thinking
uh
um
sean's the show starts in 30 minutes
giving dudes wood
sorry if i'm giving you guys wood
but
it's just my natural sex appeal i can't
control it and i refuse to and if you're
turned on by this i'm so sorry brother
but i'm just very racist guy
um but yeah i mean the show actually
starts in an hour and i have a lot of
time
would you let your girl be in an open
relationship would i let my girl yeah i
would let myself be in an open
relationship and part of that
means letting her be in an open
relationship
and yeah i would definitely let her be
in an open relationship
because i think that's the way to go
monogamy does it work does it not i
think that we are coming from a society
that is super monogamous so we think
that that's the only way of doing things
but i do not think so i think that there
are many different ways of having sex
it's just difficult because the whole
society has to change instead of just
uh
one person so you can't you when you're
[ __ ] you're being a part of something
larger than yourself
and um
and i think that um
i think it's hard to change society
overall i think it's easier to change
individuals
but yeah i think that overall
that we need to improve society
uh and the way we [ __ ] and i think like
the way of thinking about sex that we
have is not very helpful or productive
and i think that
we should um
we should really improve the way we [ __ ]
and instead of just being jealous
and petty we should uh
instead be um
[ __ ] a lot of people
and if you meet someone that [ __ ]
better than your boyfriend then why the
[ __ ] are you with your boyfriend what
you want to just be with your boyfriend
because of a lack of options
you just want to be with him because
you
signed up for him first and now you're
stuck in a no-bid contract
[ __ ] people and find the best one for
you and just because your girlfriend is
[ __ ] someone else doesn't mean that
she doesn't love you
but obviously if you're out with a girl
who's just hitting on everyone and being
a flirt that can be annoying and that
can be embarrassing
and obviously you need to be with
someone who makes you feel good and
you know doesn't embarrass you in public
um
but yeah
i think that overall like we need to be
more mature about how we're thinking
about how we think about [ __ ]
and
i would like eventually to live in a
world where we can [ __ ] freely instead
of constrained constrainedly
uh how's that on luminol i don't know
what luminol is
parents raise children well it takes a
village to raise a child so i think we
should have more daycares and more
structure to our
parent parent child rearing
but instead we have a very stunted
system
and i think we should have a
system where
people help out to raise a child instead
of nuclear families that are helpful to
raise an agrarian
society instead we should have a society
that is modern and adapts to the time
instead of just trying to preserve our
old feudal ways of thinking about family
and children
[Music]
oh god
should i steal
everything from everyone all at the same
time
five
five five
oh [ __ ] i can't do [ __ ]
what do i want with life
who am i deep inside
if he builds two roads he can cut me off
i just hope he chooses not to
and now we wait
so that uh yeah it should get going
james watkins thank you for the
compliment the philippines raises kids
right it's two parents great working is
kind of not that great
yes two parents working is not that
great you need more parents oh you
[ __ ] you need more parents working at
the same time i'm losing right now
oh yeah way to go steal from the guy
that's losing
he got sheep'd
why would you do that [ __ ]
i'm so pissed off right now
black
you know i never liked black
the color i mean the the player not the
race
just kidding i love black people has
thoughts on kids taking hormones and
luminol for gender transition and
dogs who prescribe
um
i think i think
that
some kids are not the right gender
i think that a lot of people
say that they're not the right gender
so that they can
[ __ ] do whatever the [ __ ] they want
um
and i think that you need to
differentiate between those two
and i don't know if anyone really has
the right
ability to do that the correct ability
to to figure out what the children
actually need
and uh i think that's sad
i think it's sad that people
are
over correcting and under correcting on
both sides i think if there is a child
that is all
transgenderish then they should be
transgendered you should transgender
that [ __ ] but if there's a child
that is not transgender but instead is
just like confused and like
sad
that you shouldn't transgender that
person you should instead not
transgender that person
and regular gender that person and just
be like no you actually just need
to like
play with the ball or something
you know
i'm even trained i'm trying with black
um so you know it takes all types
it just really depends
[Applause]
um
but yeah i mean it's it's not something
that we have like the right mindset on i
think that if
we were to
um figure it out it would be better
but uh i don't think we do
i think we're just fighting and being
angry at each other and using these
people who are suffering from real
medical condition
as
bait to [ __ ] piss each other off
and the real victims are the people that
are transgender and they can't get their
[ __ ] right
or people that are tricked into being
transgender
because it's
like the trendy thing to do and it's
like oh you feel a little outcast you're
like a four
in high school and you don't know any
other way of being
then you're probably transgender like i
don't think that's right either
i think like
i think it's like a society that's built
on
it's a society that's built on [ __ ]
praising
um
the individual and the physical instead
of the mental
and so instead of like you know having
a place where um
people are valued for something more
than they're physical they're valued for
their physical
and if you're physically not that great
then you're going to be like oh i must
be transgender that's
but like maybe your area of expertise is
not in the physical at all like you
don't need to be in the physical you can
just be a mental creature
a being of
uh
intellect
but we don't reward the intellect
intellect and our society is dying and
decaying on the branch
and so everyone feels like they need to
make it physically and that's just not
always the case sometimes physically
you're nothing like it's stephen hawking
it doesn't [ __ ] matter what your
physical is
work on your mental mental is way more
important to human beings we're mental
creatures if you praise the physical go
[ __ ] a chimp or a tiger or a deer
they're way better than us physically
we're not physical beings and we're
trying to be physical beings and shove
our little [ __ ] into [ __ ]
you know like the prettiest physical
thing out there and i don't i don't just
don't think that's where our expertise
lies and it's just a sick society that
just
sees the
the physical as the ultimate
and the physical is important but it's
not the ultimate thing that we should
all be striving towards
so yeah i think that's just what it is
it's just like people that uh are told
like physical physicality is the most
important thing
you don't have physicality oh [ __ ] this
game's over
um and they're trying to
figure their [ __ ] out in a in a physical
way but it's more of a mental problem
work on math get better at math
okay i'm done
i'm sorry i'm not mad at you guys i'm
mad at the situation
um
uh okay
oh angel
you can praise the physical like arnold
schwarzenegger you can praise physical
strength yeah well we shouldn't we have
forklifts we don't need physical
strength angel marquez what we need is
more intellectual strength and that's
something you lack
i'm smarter than you [ __ ]
trying to act like
you're smarter than me when you're like
oral schwarzenegger is what we should